>> COULD HAVE BEEN STOPPED IN
CHINA BEFORE IT STARTED.
AND IT WASN’T.
THE WHOLE WORLD IS SUFFERING
BECAUSE OF IT.
IF THEY WERE KNOWINGLY
RESPONSIBLE CERTAINLY.
IF THEY, IF IT WAS A MISTAKE A
MISTAKE IS A MISTAKE BUT IF THEY
WERE KNOWINGLY RESPONSIBLE,
THEN, YEAH, THERE SHOULD BE
CONSEQUENCES.
PETE: PRESIDENT TRUMP SUGGESTS
CHINA COULD FACE CONSEQUENCES
OVER CORONAVIRUS THEY WERE
KNOWING RESPONSIBLE?
AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF THE WUHAN
LAB SPEAKING PUBLICLY FOR THE
FIRST TIME, TELLING CHINESE
STATE BROADCASTER, AS WE SAID
EARLY ON NO WAY THIS VIRUS CAME
FROM US.
WE HAVE A STRICT CODE OF
RESEARCH SO WE ARE CONFIDENT OF
THAT OUR NEXT GUEST SAYS IT IS
TIME IS NOT NOW TO FORGET THE
TRUE NATURE OF THE VIRUS.
JIM, THANKS FOR BEING WITH US,
THIS MORNING THEY SAY NO CHANCE
IT COULD HAVE COME FROM THEM.
>> WELL IT ALMOST CERTAINLY DID
AND THE QUESTION WHETHER IT CAME
FROM THE WUHAN LAB WHETHER IT
CAME FROM ANOTHER SOURCE, THEY
COVERED IT UP ONCE IT STARTED
AND THAT’S THE TRUE CRIME
AGAINST HUMANITY.
THEY KNEW IT WAS HUMAN TO HOUMA
TRANSMISSIBLE.
THEY HID IT FROM THE WORLD.
THEY DISAPPEARED THE EVIDENCE
AND DISAPPEARED THE DOCTORS AND
TAKE AWAY OUR CHANCE POTENTIALLY
STOPPING IT FROM BECOMING A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
PETE: WHAT SHOULD THE PRESIDENT
DO TO MAKE THEM BAY BECAUSE WE
KNOW THE EVIL NATURE OF THIS
REGIME?
>> THEY CAN’T BE TRUSTED AND WE
CAN’T DISENTANGLE OURSELVES FROM
CHINA AS WE WOULD LIKE TO.
SECRETARY MNUCHIN SAID WE SHOULD
HELP U.S. COMPANIES THAT DO WORK
IN CHINA TO COME BACK HERE, COME
BACK TO THE UNITED STATES THIS
IS PERFECT "ART OF THE DEAL"
MOMENT FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE HAS GOT ALL THE LEVERAGE
BECAUSE THE WORLD KNOWS THIS IS
CHINA’S PROBLEM.
HE SHOULD USE THAT TO MAKE SOME
MASSIVELY GOOD FOR US, TRADE
DEALS WITH THE CHINESE.
PETE: JIM, PUT US INSIDE OF THE
HEAD OF THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY.
WHAT IS THE PLAY BEHIND COVERING
UP, DISAPPEARING SCIENTISTS,
DELAYING LETTING THE WORLD KNOW,
DENYING ON THE BACK END, EVEN
ALL THE EVIDENCE IS AGAINST YOU,
WHAT ARE THE COMMUNISTS TRYING
TO DO?
>> AVOID BLAME.
YOU KNOW THE NICE THING ABOUT AN
AUTHORITARIAN REGIME IS YOU CAN
DO THINGS LIKE MAKE A CITY
DISAPPEAR.
THEY MORE OR LESS DISAPPEARED
WUHAN FOR A WHILE.
THEY SHUT IT DOWN.
THEY RAN PEOPLE AWAY.
AND WHAT THEY DID WAS USE THEIR
AUTHORITARIAN, TOTALITARIAN
POWERS TO SHUT DOWN MEDIA, SHUT
DOWN ANY ABILITY TO REPORT AND
THEY TRIED TO HIDE IT HOPING IT
WOULD GO AWAY.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR THE WORLD IT
DIDN’T AND NOW IT IS TIME TO
HOLD THEM AND GLOBAL
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE W.H.O.
THAT HELPED THEM, THAT COLLUDED
TO HIDE THEM FROM THE WORLD,
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE IN SOME
SORT OF TRIBUNAL OR LET’S FIRE
THE WHOLEUP OF THE W.H.O. AND
START OVER.
PETE: ABSOLUTELY I COULD NOT
AGREE MORE.
NOW IS PRECISELY THE TIME TO
BRING ALL THAT MANUFACTURING,
ALL THE BUSINESS HOME HERE, AND
FOLLOW THE ABCS ANYWHERE ABOUT
CHINA.
JIM HANSEN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH,